i always try to go as deep into my
subconscious why is it that i'm gonna
try wanna play this guy why is it that
i'm attracted to it why who is he and
how is he somehow deeply rooted in my
own
psyche
[Music]
godfather coda the death of michael
corleone
i first heard that they were making
another
installment of the godfather like in the
80s or late 70s 8 1980 i forget now i
was doing a movie for for poor paramount
my second or third movie and mr mancuso
was the head of the studio at the time
frank mancuso came to have lunch with
myself and his son frank mancuso junior
was producing the film and he said what
are you doing in september i'd like you
to be in the godfather and play this
character of innocent so i said let me
check my schedule i'll get right back to
you what does all this have to do with
me
well he's going on behind your back
saying michael corleone all the time
that's it that's one thing it has to do
with you right say to his face one time
say to his face one time
mr corleone all bastards are liars
shakespeare wrote poems
what did i do this guy
didn't have alaris who was a great
production designer always said that
francis's scripts are like a newspaper
they come out every day you know
sometimes there'll be some new ideas
that he'd write and present him on the
day to do but basically the character
was you know established in the the
first screenplay that we kept he kept
adjusting but the character was there
i remember having lunch when we started
rehearsals and he'd have these big
dinners after the rehearsal
that he would cook and the cast the
whole cast would be there and mario
puzzle was there and i sat one of the
nights with mario i said mario what can
you tell me about vincent if i remember
correctly he said he has the strength of
sonny the
intelligence of veto the coldness of
michael and the warmth of fredo and i
said thank you very much i'll work on
that you know
you know obviously he's carrying all
this sort of dna in him vito corleone
came you know to ellis island and
godfather too having fled his country
where his father was killed they stamped
him vito corleone for me there was a lot
of personal parallels
inherent in the mythology of of the
corleones and
the generation of my father my father
had to flee a country
because of the repression and the lack
of freedoms that were being established
so those things are part of the
subconscious of what you draw on in any
character you try to open those doors
your father
my brother we were opposites
we would fight and argue
but i never doubted his love
he would do anything for me
but his temper
too much
cloudy this reason
i don't want you to make that mistake
al has been such an inspiration to me
and to all actors of all generations all
of his life since he first stepped on
the boards you know and one of the
things that i noticed that almost every
day of the week we'd have dinner
together with diane and my wife and i
and with the kids you're going to bring
the kids you got to bring the kids you
know if you want to bring the kids i'm
bringing my dog you bring the kids and
then we'd have dinner like that all the
time you know and there was a
a a
love and a fam familiar thing that
happened between us we didn't have to
play
it was just all it was there you know
and that for al as an artist was kind of
part of the preparation it's not like we
had to run lines or
rehearse a scene it was about building
the relationship the real relationship
which leads to a dramatic moment which
he says you know i am your son command
me
as you will
that's the price you pay
for the life you choose
anybody who's ever known him or worked
with him can only say that what an
extraordinary privilege
which is 11.
okay tell me about benedict that guy's a
machine good afternoon mr bennett he
arrives at the bellagio every day at 2pm
same car same driver benedict all right
tommy how's the baby very well thank you
remembers every valet's name on the way
in
not bad for a guy worth three quarters
of a billion jeffrey curling the costume
designer said he wanted terry's costumes
to have an eastern flare to give you a
sort of zen cool how did that inform the
character kirkland designed that he had
bought all these vintage kimono fabrics
and we made a series of vests
with these kimono fabrics which have us
you know sheen and texture we talked
about it we came to sort of like the
idea to do kind of like a nehru jacket
kind of indian you know collar so it did
look like he was a guy that was into
sort of eastern philosophy the art of
war and all that kind of stuff you know
he was precise it's like and
okay let's go
he's moving and moving moving moving
like a shark he doesn't stop like i said
i'm a shame you build the characters
with the people you work with you know
and uh soderbergh we we met with
chatting and i said i feel he's like a
shark moving through the thing you know
if some if if someone sees him coming he
knows that you have information from me
so i'm going to keep going you got to
fall into place
and give me the information
because you know you only have like 18
seconds with me from when i go from
there in the casino to there all you
need is a little gem and then you kind
of you're set in the you're setting the
character and again you got the shoes
man you got other right shoes if you
look down at the ground right shoes
you're not in character you recently
were released from prison is that
correct
that's right
now disappear to be out about the same
danny was just about i just stopped by
to say hi to tess for old times say
stay and have a drink you can't
i wasn't in the rat pack group i was the
outsider you know but of course in
between takes and you know the process
of doing the movie we're all enjoying
the making of as they say you know the
more time you spend with the actors that
are in your family and the piece the
more you're like you're going to feel
like a family all those actors had a
mutual respect
and and and admiration and this and
friendship either was already
established before the movie or quickly
established during the movie we talked
about the most important work is done
off camera not on camera you know so
that the generosity of spirit is always
the best towards your fellow actor
the untouchables
[Music]
what's that you say
i said that you're a lion member
of a no good race
it's much better than you you stinking
irish pig
oh i like him of course of course he was
the hero of growing up in the 60s he was
the cat you know and there were others
of course steve you know steve mcqueen
and james coburn and people that were
sort of in the
uh action hero you know that kind of
genre but sean was james bond you know
he was ready a couple takes and if you
want to do a third take it was like do
you have any film in that camera like
let's go
everybody do their job let's get through
this we know what we need to do kind of
you know work ethic you know which i
really appreciated and he was extremely
funny and dry and a great joy to to be a
part of that experience with him we
became friends which was a
give it up to the men upstairs you know
i can't believe it
let's take
it wasn't in the script the horseback
riding thing it was something that was
sprung on me when i got to chicago and
the palmer took me to his office shows a
storyboard he had done a little index
cards with little stick figures that he
drew sort of like what he saw and then
he got to one of them he said and here
you guys are going to be those are you
four guys on horseback
i said a horseback i didn't read that
there was no horse no i'm going to be on
horseback we're going to be attacking
this bridge just crossing the missouri
river
and i said oh that's going to be i
thought great sequence you know but i
said but you know brian i said my my
character is from the south side of
chicago never been on a horse and he
looked at me without missing a beat he
said no he's an expert horseman i said
okay
i said when are we shooting this thing
you know i found a uh
in i think it's called hyde park in
chicago there was a horse stable there
for people to rent horses
so i thought oh great my grandfather
was an immigrant went to work in the
stables and he would take me to work
with him on the weekends or after school
and go
and he taught me how to ride and that's
why i i'm an expert horsewood but i said
now that's fine for the backstory but
now i actually have to learn how to ride
overs so i started going to that
those stables and getting on a horse as
often as i could and then when it was
time to shoot it was just a question of
not falling off the horse at the speed
we were going because my horse was like
michael jordan you know i had to hold on
and carry his like 30 pound tommy gun
and only hold on to the range he
couldn't hold on to
you know the horn you were free
freestyling like this you know it was it
was hairy i want to talk a little bit
more about working with de palma you
said that he had storyboarded the whole
thing yeah what was his style like he
was very well prepared and had designed
the movie you know he was always been a
master of designing those sequences like
the sequence in the train station or the
baby carriage
[Music]
come on come on let's get out of here
what are you doing shut up come on shut
up
obviously it was an inspiration he got
from
the battleship potemkin sequence but he
he did his own thing with it and he
designed his incredible seat it's really
an incredible sequence it's just a whole
tension of that with the morikone score
is really one of the classic sequences i
think people will look at for a long
time to come
internal affairs
the project was developed for me you
know at paramount i would i did not have
a part in the development of it once i
got involved
naturally you have some opinions about
certain things and you say what about
this do we think that you know because
you're in the creative process at that
point i box for a while for the
character i think there's even a shot in
the movie or in my house where you see
me and you know i wanted him to have
that kind of background you know a kid
that grew up like golden gloves in los
angeles and not that we never see
us boxing but what happens is i think
you know because when you learn how to
box there's a way you you throw punches
a train punch and you know where you
know where your leverage is you know
there is this one scene where i where i
knock
at richard gere's character then it's
packed down with one with just one
the actors look for that all the time
little additions or contradictions to
what you would expect
mamma mia here we go again
[Music]
there's a story behind your casting
there apparently cher had requested that
you play the role of hernandez that's
what the director said and i said you
know thank you for the opportunity he
goes cher picked you
and i said you know she had like a
lineup or what's going on and you guys
said yeah i kind of you know i thanked
her i said i heard you picked me or
whatever she would of course what the
gliani of course i guess she liked that
movie and
and you know kind of a deal closer i
guess
[Music]
there's no regrets
[Music]
it was a natural thing it was very easy
the the track was pre-recorded we went
into the studio there in london and
we just did it you know we went through
it until he was happy and said we got it
i said okay
father of the bride
my daughter when they saw it they kind
of said daddy there's nothing like you
you know
but he is all of me at the same time and
all of the and all and all of the
fathers that i've experienced that
somehow made
sense to this guy and there are key
things in the film that that are
important to
where you find the comedy they fall into
place with a lot of the fathers that i
grew up including myself traditional and
conservative like to have a good time
but they're family first very strong
work work ethic and because they came to
this country again as
exiles in this case
they had to
build a new life where there was they
came as a lawyer and they were a waiter
and then worked their way back to school
and get a law degree or doc you know
people did that and then that journey
creates a certain pride
of ownership of that or
also saying that that's what
the opportunity this country has given
us is a responsibility to deliver and do
do right by the journey that they've
brought you here you know there's a
responsibility to contribute and to be
positive a member of society and take
advantage of the opportunity that was
taken away from you in your home country
so he's the character of that cut like
that because he feels that way so
strongly above certain things of course
he steps in puddles because he's not
looking down he's looking there's a
certain you know tonality that you're
working under it's not going to be also
a drama you know but this there could be
warmth and touching moments and all that
but there there's a there's a buoyancy
that has to have to happen i always kind
of envisioned i i saw him or i saw
myself
in a sort of character as a sort of a
keaton-esque character the [ __ ] is
happening around them and he's so
overwhelmed it's sometimes so
overwhelming that he's even noticed
what's happening around them those kind
of things kind of stick in your head
somehow and start spitting out a
character